- Les véhicules blindés
canadiens commandés par
le gouvernement haïtien sont
arrivés à l'aéropà l'aéroport d-
Prince, sous le regard aiguisé
de résidents qui ont capté
la scène avec leur appareil.
L'opération était prévue
depuis des mois.
L'équipement servira à soutenir
la police nationale d'Haïti,
la PNH, qui a perdu le contrôle
de la capitale, gangrenée
par des gangs lourdement armés.
HENRI-PAUL NORMANDIN, ancien
ambassadeur du Canada en Haïti
- La PNH est débordée.
Elle a besoin de plus de moyens
et l'envoi de ces blindés-là va
justement renforcer la capac
de la PNH à faire son travail.
- Le coeur du pays est secoué
par les manifestations et les
violences. Et la légitimité
du premier ministre Ariel Henry
est contestée depuis un an.
Les États-Unis ont déjà déclarér
leur présence sur le plan
humanitaire, après la demande
d'aide militaire du gouvernement
haïtien.
En entrevue aux "Coulisses
du pouvoir", l'ambassadeur
du Canada en Haïti rappelle
que Ottawa a investi des
millions pour renforcer la PNH
et que la solution à la crise
passe par la police haïtienne.
SÉBASTIEN CARRIÈRE
ambassadeur du Canada en Haïti
- Mais cette annéesi,
il y a eu des annonces qui ont
été faites, environ
42 millions de dollars
en nouvelles contributions
pour la PNH. Pour nous,
ion durable aux
problèmes de sécurité
en Haïti, c'est le renforcement
de la police nationale d'Haïti.
- Cette livraison fait planer
le spectre d'une intervention
étrangère, mal perçue d'une
"Je suis à la rue car j'ai
appris que les forces étrangères
allaient fouler le sol haïtien",
explique ce manifestant.
- Malheureusement, on est dans
une situation où on essaie
de choisir la moins pire
des solutions. Et quelle est
la moins pire des solutions?Este
intervention par une force
multinationale, dont dans
le fond, ni les Haïtiens,
ni la communauté internationale,
ne souhaitent, essentielleme
d'une part. Ou bien, est-ce
qu'on laisse les gens continuer
à souffrir?
- Le secrétaire généraldes Natir
du déploiement immédiat d'une
force multinationale.
Le Conseil de sécurité doit
se réunir la semaine prochaine
au sujet d'Haïti.
Ici, Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.